[Music]
hey I found some food
looks really good - good good good
trying to focus right look don't my dad
said man just before I got me there
because I wasn't that obvious too busy
obsessing on my gamma-ray experiments
finished my father's death because I was
focusing on my destiny but I didn't miss
my father's death because he was
murdered right in front of me
by my sister whom I didn't even know
existed because she was kept a secret
from me my whole life look terrible
comparison just had nothing to do with
what you're going through and my family
it's like would cost to fight amongst
ourselves while everyone else suffers
for it no I was gods and rooms and well
this is sister hello
I don't even know if I haven't veto your
for you could kill your sister thought
without each other
you're not the god hammers here Dumbo
doesn't sound like a compliment it's
totally a compliment Dumbo Dumbo sounds
like you're calling me Dumbo over and
over again
Dumbo home say once more I'll tell ya
elephant think she can fly because it
was a magical feather and then he loses
his feather when Danny realizes didn't
have anything to do with him flying at
all feather man would I come from was
that me the whole time you go to the
tail didn't even say anything we're here
yeah yeah get rid of it
[Music]
Ramar will approach me they said we want
to really change up the franchise we
want to take fall in a new direction
we want to have an adventure and make it
funny I will tower over the mountains
and vary my sword deep in a spur give it
a second I remember the first time
reading the script I did laughing out
loud or not I swear I'm not even moving
it's just doing this on its own right
the character felt different
you